bonjour à tous alors maintenant on va
parler de alexandre deux chapelles des
chapelles je pars comme on dit donc
quitter aussi un très bon joueur
qui a été un moment le meilleur joueur
du monde en fait après après philidor
mais qui est aussi très bon dans
d'autres jeux notamment le whist d'après
ce que j'ai pu lire donc le whist
parement c'était l'ancêtre du bridge
voilà donc pareil de chapelles pas trop
de partis et je voudrais choisi une
celle là où ils allaient noir contre
cochrane cochrane joueur britannique
réalisé son nom au gambie cochrane je
crois que c'est dans l'italienne
et donc une partie où il donne le
premier set plus les avantages du très à
son aise sur terre que le 4 et les
blancs peuvent rejouer alors juste comme
j'avais du mal avec le pg ng du jeu les
coûts noir n'en vaut dans la pratique
s'est passé c'est que là c'était trop
dangereux et il a joué des 4 et la
partie a commencé là pour lui il a joué
6 etc
mais comme il a joué avec eux six des
cinq communes françaises je vais élan de
temps voilà je dire qu'il a fait des six
mais normalement fait on était comme ça
très haut blanc il a joué f4 avec les
blancs du sud alors bien sûr pour que me
qualifier 3 pour se développer très bien
mais bon ok il a fait 4 et d5 et ça ils
ont vraiment eu cette position sur
l'échiquier donc sur quoi la nique au
crâne à jouer eux cinq c5 donc comme
dans une française on attaque un peu le
centre et c3 alors normalement c'est
très bien dans la française remporte le
centre mais juste ici un peu comme kf3
manière très naturelle étant donné
qu'après ces prend dès qu'elle va les
prendre en fait on peut très bien ne pas
voir de pions là puisqu'on a déjà fait 4
qui soutient le 5
donc le quai l'un des quatre serait sur
une forte case mettrait la pression sur
six est évidemment quand on commence la
partie avec un pur - à des blancs sont
beaucoup mieux qu'en mai bref il a fait
ces trois cas ici six cavaliers v3c
prend des s'éprend d'un v6 qui haïssez
trois fous dusautoir jusqu'à présent des
cours à peu près normal
les blancs ont fait à 3 bon pourquoi pas
si c'est dans l'idée de jouer b4 parce
que ça prendra de l'espace talel dame et
de deux ça libérerait le fou qui pour
l'instant doit défendre b2 mais si le
pion est parti en b 4 alors on prend le
développer ce soit 11,3 soit en b2 à ce
moment là et aussi et que le plan b 4 on
peut jouer des manoeuvres comme cavalier
à 4k et c5 donc là trois dans l'esprit
pas trop mal il a fait cavalier h6 et
lincou j'aime pas tu sers à rien qui
fait des trous ch3 joué par les blancs
il était bien plus malin de juin coûts
de développement comme food et 3 1 par
exemple qui au passage interdit
cavaliers f5 puisque on pour
le prendre et sur qui on comprend qu'on
gagnerait le pion des 5 qui serait plus
protégés bien sûr faut des trois bosses
pas tant pour tendre un piège
on peut jamais prendre ce plan des 4
c'est un piège classique dans la
française puisque les échecs et on gagne
la dame qui n'est plus protégé ouais
donc après foot est roi l'a fait les
gens comme vous et 7 et éventuellement
b4 voilà comment disent ah ça libère le
fou ça permet cavaliers à 4 kgs c5
ensuite ces voix là bas les blancs sont
beaucoup mieux sans sans trop de
surprise mais il joue h3 donc qui sert à
rien je trouve pas ce que kelly g4 de
toute façon on n'avait pas vu revenir
dessus et ça fait des trous donc il
vient f5 et il vient appuyer un peu sur
la faiblesse de la case au passage
évidemment en attaque des quatre donc
les blancs défendent avec a lieu deux
mais du coup passif difficile de sortir
ce fou et et ses impacts larqué nord
soit beaucoup moins bien maintenant faut
s'être ils le chassent avec g4 là le
câblier attaqué alors on aurait très
bien pu choquer hk traquer noir juste un
bon coup un bon coup mais il a fait
flasher 4 ichec prise prise est
effectivement pas si simple pour les
landes compte tenu du développement
puisque le fou peut pas l'en g2 et si on
bouge le cavalier on perd des quatre
mais trouve un moyen astucieux et
ferrand f2i est chassé le cavalier avec
le roi petit rock enragé trois attaques
lecavalier y rentrer chez lui b4 bon
pourquoi pas peut-être y avait d'autres
choses à faire mais pourquoi pas et à 5
à 5 bien joué bien casser un peu la
chaîne de pions blancs créé un nouveau
front sur sur les dames et là je pense
pas très bonne réaction des blancs il a
fait fou des deux qui va rendre le pion
tant qu'à faire je pense que b5 était
plus approprié donc on le rend aussi
mais au moins on peut continuer le
développement et et puis peut-être
torbey a ensuite on pourra re bouger
ceux qui avaient peut-être en c3 ou quoi
le fouillent un rang des 3 et s'il est
blanchi l'histoire développement bon bah
ça va ils ont commencé la partie qu'un
pion plus ils ont rendu un maison la
paire de foule avantages des espaces
allaient droit d'être des attaques
possibles
ça serait raisonnable mais bon alors les
bleus ont fait flou des deux est bas sur
quoi ils n'en ont pris en b 4 il a pris
du fou qui avait les preuves si on prend
un point donc il a récupéré son pur -
mais on voit bâclé nord sont plutôt
mieux que le roi blanc semble faible
la tour va avoir son mot à dire sur la
colonne a toujours gardé quatre et il
est blond ne soit pas trop fine
développement alors il a fait tomber un
bon c'est plutôt pas mal de garder la
tour parce que si on veut tout reprendre
à 8 tours prend 1,8 balle et noir
allaient rentrer en force par ici donc
quelque part dangereux pour les blancs
dont coq et or bien normal il a fait
tour à trois échecs bon droit se cache
et repart avec sa dame s'engouffrer de
l'autre côté donc plutôt pas mal
là les blancs jouent sans peur tout
reprend bessette bon je dois dire
c'était peut-être intéressant 17
défendre le roi plus tôt mais du coup
d'un match 4 et on va les problèmes la
dame qui peut arriver par là etc
ce terrain est là l'erreur décisive des
blancs enfin finale en tout cas je dois
repris on 17 et sur quoi les noirs ont
un math imparable donc je peux vous
laisser chercher s'ils voulaient mettre
en pause
sinon pour les autres on va regarder la
suite de la partie il a fait damer de
échec honteux sera un exercice qu'on
pourrait avoir dans le puzzle rush je
sais pas si vous y jouez c'est pas mal
hein c'est une option de jeu menant sur
sur che ce com où vous avez cinq minutes
pour faire le plus de petits puzzles un
exercice possible au bout de trois
heures vous avez perdu et il faut aller
vite et bien voilà
fou j'ai deux en tout cas et tout
reproche trois très bien joué les blancs
sont bleus de prendre avec le roi et
d'un match quatre matins voilà donc
c'est une partie donc de ce joueur
alexandre des chapelles jouer donc en
1821 ou au café de la régence comme
comme très souvent à l'époque the place
to be
et voilà on voit qu'ils jouaient mieux
quoi il a commencé la partie avec un
pion - des noirs et l'asie joue deux
coups il a quand même battu un joueur
comme cochrane je pense qu'ils étaient
pas mal à son époque
s'il l'est c'est son nom dans l'histoire
avec un gambit sais c'est que c'est un
des joueurs célèbres et voilà donc
donc voilà c'est un très bon joueur on
regardera pas d'autres parties de lui
mais voilà c'était juste pour pour en
dire un petit mot il méritait sa place
dans dans cette série voilà et ben à
bientôt pour la suite